And he had a lot of groupies
and he took and you know he,
he forgot they were filming was Mike and
he had a lot of group laid the law down.
Jump on him. That's
hilarious. I need to see that.
I was telling you about uh,
American made the movie with Tom Cruise
and other bad ass Tom cruise movie.
Oh yeah, we see he's on the airplanes.
You was just jumping around. Yeah, do it.
It's good. It's really good.
It's a good movie. They look,
I know a lot of the Barry seal
story and they covered a lot of,
you can only cover so much of it and
a 90 minute movie. But yeah, look,
I mean they did not pull any punches.
They made look like Bill Clinton got 'em
off. Bill Clinton called the prosecutor.
They caught him with millions of dollars
of and cocaine and money phone call.
Nope. Nope. They have her on the phone
with Bill Clinton. Bill Clinton, who like,
he's telling her I'm going to walk.
Whether or not he said that,
I don't know cause he's dead. No one
knows. Right. And he's telling her it was,
trust me,
I'm going to walk right out of here.
And they're all laughing and she's like,
you're not going to walk anyway.
And they're like, Mrs Prosecutor,
Bill Clinton's on the phone,
and it's governor Clinton. Yes. Yeah.
And you see your group, you see,
just get pissed off.
The next thing you know,
they're unconfident and he's leaving.
So they would let you know
that Bill Clinton, if they,
if the only way you could put that in the
movie is there has to be truth, right?
Some truth to him,
they're like,
there's gotta be some sort of a documented
record of him making that call. Right.
He made that call. He had to have made
that call. You couldn't defamation,
of course, Clinton.
And he is the governor.
So there's probably a record
of him saying, let that guy go.
And so the reason they think
is because in the film,
this is what they're saying is that he
was tied in with the CIA and somehow or
another through the CIA using him for
reconnaissance photos and stuff like that.
And the eventually got hooked up. These
drug dealers and started selling drugs.
The CIA was in on it and
they were allowing him to do
it and he was getting them
photographs and Intel from all
these different drug places.
And in return they were letting him do
whatever he did and taking a piece of it
problems, which you mentioned
Mena Arkansas. Yeah, yeah.
They mentioned all the,
all the,
I mean that's where Bill Clinton was
the governor of the only found out about
all this stuff because two kids
were killed. They were murdered.
And they told the parents that the kids
had gotten high and fell asleep on the
train tracks.
But the parents did an independent
autopsy and found stab wounds in the kits.
So like, oh Jesus, what
the fuck happened here?
And then slowly but surely the whole thing
unravels. They witnessed a drug drop.
Yeah. And uh, well they
couldn't have any witnesses.
They made mean like it
was lit case he killed,
go to youtube and just punch
in a CIA, Mena, Arkansas,
cocaine blow. And you get the
host. It's a sear. It's like,
it could be at two kids. We
don't know. We don't know.
Somebody who was in our assume the CIS.
The kids must have seen the drugs be
dropped and whoever was selling the drugs,
moving the drugs,
they just decided to kill these kids
cause they couldn't take a chance.
The kids keeping their mouth
shut so they killed them.
And apparently that was just
one thing though in the movie,
the way they haven't made up is like that.
That was just one thing that's sort
of straw that broke the camel's back.
They don't even have that.
And I don't even remember if they
had that in the movie. The kids,
did they have that in the
movie? The murder? They didn't
have the murder, the kids.
No they didn't. But what they
did have is these people were,
I mean everybody was rich.
There were all coming in and
buying things and everyone's like,
where the fuck is all this
money coming from? Who is rich?
The people that we're working with,
Barry seal's like his brother in law,
like his wife's brother apparently.
I don't know if that was a real person,
but in the, in the movie, he's, he's
balling out of control and he's, uh,
he's got some fucking ridiculous souped
up car and he's got money coming out of
his pockets and he stuffed in his pocket
and he gets caught by a cop. You know,
and I don't know if that
happened in real life,
but in the movie they made it
seem like everybody was just,
there was so much money flowing around.
It didn't make any sense.
They were burying it in his
backyard. They, when they busted him,
it was like in the movie. Now again,
I don't know if this was real.